hi there steve coffin here and today i'm
going to do a video we are
driving from
zadar in
croatia to trogir
and stop by the roadside here this is
the kirka national park
and you can see a catamaran out in the
distance presumably heading out to the
ocean
beautiful city zadar zadar
in fact all the cities that we've come
to and towns here in in dalmatia and
croatia have been spectacular but today
i want to talk about failure in language
learning okay because
prior to coming to croatia for about
10 days two weeks almost
i worked hard on croatian i went through
all 60 of our many stories
understand them i have a good sense of
how the language works
and then i come to croatia and i have
been essentially unable to speak any
croatian
so to that extent it's a failure i was
hoping that i'd be speaking croatian
there are a number of reasons
and i think these are
the kinds of problems that many of us
face in language learning first of all
when i try to say something i can't
remember all the words
that i have learned because actually
language learning takes time so even
though croatian is in a way easy because
i know other slavic languages
yet when i try to remember the words
some other slavic word comes out which
might be from ukrainian or russian or
whatever so it's very difficult to pull
out the words that i know that i have
and of course the other problem here is
that everyone speaks english so well in
croatia it's it's
right on a par with holland we were in
holland for one evening everyone speaks
english so well and people
are not going to humor me necessarily
they you know smile and acknowledge the
fact that i said you know nobody utro
good morning but
you know if a person is working in a
restaurant or in a hotel they just want
to get on with what they have to do and
they're not going to humor me
so realistically in croatian
i have to recognize that it's going to
take longer even though i know other
slavic languages and i also have to get
in a sort of a protected situation
talking to people in other words a tutor
if i had had even five online line
sessions
with a croatian tutor it would have
started getting the language to come out
because after a while
you know with all of the sort of input
activities you have to start activating
it and you i find that it's very
difficult to activate it in a real
situation unless
everyone here only spoke croatian and
i've had a couple of situations where i
needed some information i was looking
for a dry cleaner and i was dealing with
people who didn't speak english and
there i had to try to say something in
croatian maybe a mixture of other slavic
words but i was able to get something
out so
i guess the conclusion is you know i say
it's a failure i didn't do what i
thought i'd be able to do in other words
come here and be able to speak croatian
but
on the other hand i recognize that it
takes time
you have to start with someone who's
helping you you can't just start with
people random people
uh in the street unless they don't speak
english so there's a genuine meaningful
need to communicate and there is no
english to help you
but the other thing is it's not a
failure really because whatever i put
into croatian i still have i can go back
to my many stories do them again it
becomes sort of like an exercise room
and i also have to do more reading and
creation i have to expand the range of
content that i'm dealing with start you
know getting into the language
and whatever i've acquired so far it's
still there i can always go back to it
even though i'm going to go back to my
arabic persian and
turkish because that's my short-term
goal whatever i put into croatian is not
lost i'd like to come back it's a
beautiful country and so it's a failure
but it's not a failure but perhaps my
expectations were unrealistic so that's
it
see you next time bye for now
this is the view out
from the tower here
let me head this way
okay young man yes
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
two
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
greece
[Music]
you